Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
In the last video we talked a little bit about the Scandinavian societies,
which proceeded the Viking Age and looked at the events going on in Scandinavia
and Europe,
which may have caused the Viking age,
and of course in this video we're going to talk about the Viking age itself.
So let's get into it.
Lindisfarne a small island off the coast of modern England.
What was then North Umbria is a classic historical example of a sitting duck on
this island was an isolated and undefended Abby hum to monks and filled with
valuable goods.
The fact that this Abby was somewhat isolated from the rest of the country was
not an isolated occurrence.
A lot of churches and such things.
We're trying to sort of settle away from the turbulent politics of their home
nations and while isolation may have been indeed beneficial to that end,
it was very enticing of foreigners,
particularly someone like the Vikings and in fact we see,
especially in the earlier days of the Viking Age,
the Viking specifically targeted these religious centers.
Possibly.
This relates back to the idea that they may have actually been encouraged to
find themselves and Christianity like we talked about in the last video,
and also especially because such sites were considerably week and on either
January or more lightly,
June eight 793 the Viking age began here on that day to small group Vikings,
perhaps 25 to 40 sale to Lindisfarne found it surprisingly vulnerable.
The English king were far too occupied and worked with each other to suspect and
prepare for an attack such as this.
The Vikings rated the Abbey killing amongst present directly or throwing them
into the ocean or enslaving them.
The English Saxon Chronicle,
obviously with a bit of added fiction record to the event and this year fierce
foreboding omens came over to the land of the north.
Some brands and their wretched people shook their were excessive whirlwinds
lightening and fiery dragons.
We're seeing flying in the sky.
These signs were followed by great feminine and then a little after those,
that same year on the sixth ides of January,
the ravaging of wretched heathen people destroyed God's church at Linda's farm.
It's certainly notable to mention that many prayers in England at this time
ended up with the phrase from the fury of the Northmen deliver us,
oh Lord.
More raids with can come and would grow in size and complexity.
Scotland and Ireland.
We're soon specifically preferred over England after the failed raid on the
Jarrow Abby,
where the Viking graders were met with resistance.
Though in time the vikings did come back for Jiro and England and general soon
followed France,
Germany,
and Eastern Europe.
These rates,
however,
we're not limited only to proximate locations in Europe,
the Vikings would even begin to travel as far as the Middle East and Byzantine
Empire.
This reinforces the fact that these rays weren't just conducted by a bunch of
drunk savages getting on a ship and then attack in the first building as they
saw the vikings,
the viking raids were often considerably well planned and got more and more
complex.
As time went on,
Europe was terrified by the northbound.
As I said earlier,
though,
the vikings were not solely interested in just going on summer pillages and then
coming home with all their bouncy.
These raids did indeed yield great rewards and did in fact in many ways to find
the vikings,
but they were also considerably interested in settling and conquering places as
well.
Not long after the raids became more popular and commonplace and Layton,
ninth and 10th century biking colonization really took off in northern Scotland.
Norwegian vikings settled Shetland Orkney and the Hebrides in Ireland.
They founded settlements such as Wexford,
limerick,
and in fact the modern capital of Ireland,
Dublin.
Some colonies were established as rating outposts and evolved over time into
actual settlements.
Many of them were largely comprised of men.
Women were brought in the settlements from the surrounding country.
At times,
conflict emerged between local inhabitants and the Viking settlers.
At other times,
coexistence was entirely possible.
Some Irish and Viking neighbors would go so far as a form.
Alliances with each other and intermarry.
England's interaction with the Vikings is of considerable importance and fame
and eight 65 to three sons of the legendary Viking King Ragnar log groke eve are
the bone lists Hoff dawn and Guth from let a force of Viking warriors into
England,
which the Anglo Saxon is called Michael Hyphen Hara a great,
he's an army is interesting by the way,
how evidence of Ragnar is existence as a week.
But these three people did in fact exist.
So an eight 67 the vikings captured the city of York and thereby Asserta control
over much of Northumbria.
They continued to push into the island until age 78 when Alfred the great King
of West six defeated them in battle saving England from total domination and
naturally earning him the title,
the great,
which is only shared with news degrade in England,
North King in English history cause he agreed to a piece and established
territories.
The agreed upon Norse territory is referred to as the Dane law,
which was around until the 11th century.
The presence of the Dane Law had a major effect on this part of history,
some of which lasts until this day conflicts that occur between the English and
the Vikings.
But there were also times of peace during which trade and interactions of all
sorts occurred.
These associations had a considerable impact on English culture and history and
in fact the English language we still,
in fact he used Viking words to this day is bog dirt,
run res Lake ill,
happy anger,
the Pronoun they,
and importantly,
being a moderately democratic people.
They gave us the word law as well as many other words,
but we'll talk about that a little bit more.
And,
uh,
upcoming video of Viking ways of life and language and religion,
things like that.
The French believed by some to be the original irritates of the vikings were not
safe from the conquest either.
Oftentimes the Frankish kings though better organized and offended at the time,
then their English counterparts were unable to fend off Viking Raiders.
Kings at such as Charles the bald and Charles is simple,
simply tried to pay the vikings off.
So these agreements were often very short lived as the vikings continuously came
back from more in 911 the Viking leader rollup besieged Paris altogether.
Charles is simple,
had no choice but to see territory,
the Vikings Kleiner territory in north Manea or the land of the Northmen or
today as it's known Normandy,
they settled in eastern Europe as well.
The particularly warlike Slavic tribes in the region even welcomed,
uh,
leadership of rubric and the Moravians Barrengi and being the word which the
Greeks gave the vikings and therefore being,
the word which is commonly used to refer to vikings in the east were Rick and
his group of Viking is from around Sweden and founded,
conquered and United towns along the Neper and vulgar rivers in modern day,
Russia and Ukraine,
they created a more coordinated siting again,
trade with foreign nations such as the Byzantine Empire,
and founded the Reus cognate,
which was a significant predecessor to modern Russia.
The Vikings did more than just trade with the Byzantines and the year 988
emperor basil.
The second form that the Va Randian card,
a unit of the Byzantine army consisting very largely of Norseman.
The emperor does trusting his own soldiers,
made them his personal guard,
and this lasted as late as the 14th century,
but even before the emperor set up this scar,
there were varying Ian's fighting and the Byzantine Empire against the emirate
of Crete and the Arab is in Syria,
the Byzantine princess and a come Nana referred to them as ax wielding
barbarians from the Thule for the Thule,
very likely meaning the British isles in Scandinavia.
It's kind of interesting to see the Norseman fighting and he's more exotic
environments.
We don't really remember the vikings as people who were involved in these
eastern and Mediterranean complex,
but it did definitely have a role to play here.
The vikings were in Italy as well at first of course to raid,
but then eventually the Italians began to enlist Bahrainian mercenaries and
their armies.
The first instance being in the early 10th century in combat against the Arabs,
and later in the 11th century,
north people actually conquered Sicily and southern Italy.
So they can see from all of this.
The vikings were a bit more than north of our bearings,
who just made a habit of ruining people's days.
They,
throughout the Viking Age,
had a major influence on all of Western civilization,
but they also expanded beyond European civilization to where no Europeans had
gone before.
And the next video,
we'll talk about how the Viking and settled places like the Faroe Islands,
Iceland,
Greenland,
and even encountered native Americans while settling North America to keep up
with the series.
And for more videos like this and on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.